yes I mean dark energy is mysterious but
it's certainly there and I think it's
there for a reason
the universe is extremely large it's
also very dark I mean not totally dark
it's also not infinitely large and it's
also not intimately empty indeed there's
something there I mean if we look at the
observed accelerated expansion of the
universe it's indicates that space is
filled with something and that's the
dark energy that we are discussing I
will explain the relationship between
dark energy and a in the expansion a
little later so I totally believe by the
way it exists it's not something that's
not there but it's not described in the
correct way our current theory which is
based on general relativity is namely
incomplete and that's my main main point
I want to make in Einstein's gravity we
think about space-time basically as
having no properties it's like a stage
on which matter moves under the
influence of forces but I think there
are reasons both from the observations
as well from theory to really challenge
that point of view that space-time is
empty or made of nothing first of all
there is indeed the fact that 95% of the
energy budget is in this mysterious
forms which is either dark matter or
dark energy but also we have insights
from string theory from black hole
physics that tell us that space time and
gravity eventually will emerge I mean it
comes about from something microscopic
in which these quantities phenomena have
no no real meaning so dark energy and
dark matter constitute this 95% of the
energy budget I mean the stars that we
see is less than 1% and if we look at
our current laws of physics we only
describe what's being observed and what
we observe are the stars and maybe the
radiation from the Big Bang but that's
only a very tiny fraction of all the
energy in our universe now in physics we
generally ignore what is happening in
the microscopic level like the air in
this room we don't generally care about
all the microscopic molecules how they
are moving we just forget this and this
is how we make our laws of physics and
also
our everyday life we talk about things
that move like the cars and so on but
not the air and in there the same is
true for space-time and our current
theories are ignoring most of the things
that are moving in our universe so I
claim that dark energy is actually the
thing that we've not described well
enough and that there's a microscopic
theory that should eventually explain
what's happening in in dark energy so I
told you I were going to talk about the
relationship between expansion and dark
energy the fact that the universe
expands means that things are moving
away from us and with higher velocities
when we are further away and eventually
there will be distance where things are
moving away with the speed of light and
there's nothing we can see beyond that
and this is what we call the horizon of
our universe so there's a finite
distance and you can think about it as a
giant dome around us where we can not
look beyond that's a set called the
horizon and there are rights other
locations where the horizon seen in our
universe which has to do with black
holes and one of the big discoveries we
have made in physics is that horizons
have very special properties and this is
a discovery due to Stephen Hawking
horizon tells us namely about how much
for a black hole how much information
eventually went into the black hole it
also tells us something that there must
be a temperature associated with the
black hole and the same is true with our
universe the universe has a lot of
information in there
which is the size of our cosmological
horizon and it's that information
eventually that we have not been able to
describe that we've been ignoring it but
it's contained in the dark energy the
dark energy tells us actually that our
our universe is not just an T but it's
being filled with something that we
still have to learn how to describe so I
think we're not there yet with our
fewest point of view we don't know
understand everything yet but I think we
live in a exciting time where we're
going to change the way we think about
gravity about space-time and we're going
to change even the way that Einstein
well describes gravity with his expiry
of curved space-time by thinking about
indeed what is the microscopic building
blocks of the space-time itself much
forum I'm doing on time or maybe even
during the discussion I can say a little
more button so yeah we'll have time all
right so my point of view is that indeed
we don't have the final theory yet and
that when we have it I think dark energy
will be the most exciting thing that's
happening there and there's lots of
equations we haven't discovered about it
yet but it's certainly an indication of
the fact that we don't have to complete
theory yet